- All this--
- [Gary] Yes.
- is most appealing
to young, right?
- If you're over 40,
are you into this?
If you're over 50?
- I think so.
- [Larry] Yeah?
- I think if you
look at behavior,
let me ask you a question.
Have you noticed some of your
over 40, over 50 friends
start to send emojis on texts?
- I don't know what that is.
- Do you know the little poop
picture and the little face
and the smiles?
- I don't text.
Well, listen,
let's turn off the cameras,
we've got things to do here.
I need Larry to send some
poop emojis immediately.
- A poop emoji?
- [Gary] Yes, poop emojis.
- [Larry] Sounds like a dog
in the backyard.
- In the next segment,
we're gonna talk poop emojis.
But, look, I think if you
look at the data it's
stunning what's
happened 35 to 60.
I'll go a different
route with you.
For anybody who's
watching right now,
if you're lucky enough to
know your parent at
the age that you are now.
If you're of an age where you
actually knew your mom and dad
at the same age you are now
you will notice that your
behavior is much younger.
Much younger.
- [Larry] Of course.
- That has a lot to
do with technology.
Technology is dragging,
people, we're living through
a youth-ification
of our society.
The fastest growing segment
on the Instagrams and Snapchats
in the world are the
40 and overs because
just like Facebook
these things age up.